madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
en attendant quelques quelques arrivées
nous poursuivons cet après-midi les
auditions de la mission d'information
que notre commission a décidé de
constituer sur la création du fond
Marianne la sélection des projets
subventionnés le contrôle de la
exécution et les résultats obtenus au
regard des objectifs du fond cette
mission d'information a obtenu du Sénat
de bénéficier des problématiques des
commissions d'enquêtes
nous entendons aujourd'hui madame Sonia
bacquez secrétaire d'État auprès du
ministre intérieur et des Outre-mer
chargé de la citoyenneté
nous savons madame la ministre que vous
avez pris vos fonctions bien après le
lancement du fond Marianne et la
sélection des projets mais alors que
ceci est encore soumis à un suivi de par
votre administration vous avez été
témoins d'un certain nombre d'alerte qui
ont conduit entre autres à la création
de notre commission d'enquête par
ailleurs vous avez autorité sur le
secrétariat général du cipdr et avait
aujourd'hui la responsabilité sur
l'attribution des crédits du fipdr nous
sommes donc particulièrement intéressés
à comprendre le suivi que vous faites de
ce sujet et les enseignements que vous
tirez de l'épisode qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui
avant de vous céder la parole pour un
bref une propos introductif si vous le
souhaitez bien sûr madame la ministre je
dois vous rappeler qu'un faux témoignage
devant une commission d'enquête est
passible de sanctions pénales qui
peuvent aller selon les circonstances de
3 à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et de 45000 à
5000 euros d'amende je vous invite donc
à prêter serment de dire de toute la
vérité rien que la vérité élevait la
main droite et dites je le jure
merci madame je vous laisse donc à
présent la parole pour quelques minutes
d'introduction
vous avez le micro
je vous remercie de modifier aujourd'hui
effectivement j'ai pris mes fonctions le
4 juillet dernier mais je vais
effectivement vous donner un propos
introductif quelques éléments de
contexte vu de mon prisme de la faire
qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui donc
quand j'arrive le 4 juillet quand je
suis nommée
je dispose à ce moment-là de ce qu'on
appelle des dossiers ministres c'est à
dire que chaque direction remet au
ministre aux membres du gouvernement un
certain nombre d'éléments
qui sont qui sont donnés à sa connaît
qui sont mis à sa connaissance pardon et
dans le dossier ministre concernant le
secrétariat général du cipdr il n'est
pas question du fond Marianne donc c'est
un sujet que je ne connais absolument
pas puisque vous le savez peut-être je
viens de Nouvelle-Calédonie en
Nouvelle-Calédonie il n'y a pas de sujet
de radicalisation donc c'est vraiment un
sujet qui mettait complètement inconnu
avant d'arriver je prends pour la
connaissance pour la première fois du
sujet dans le courant du mois de
septembre mon conseiller en
communication me transmet un article de
la du magazine Marianne qui date du 30
juin donc d'avant ma nomination faisant
état d'un d'une question sur la liste
des lauréats qui qui n'aurait pas été
rendu public donc je demande à ce
moment-là via mon directeur de cabinet
des éléments au secrétaire général du
cipdr qui transmet qui nous transmet
pardon une première note que nous
estimons incomplète et qui est complété
par une seconde note qui date du 12
octobre
pour nous expliquer d'une part la raison
pour laquelle les les la liste de
lauréat n'est pas rendue publique et je
lui reviendrai sans doute et d'autre
part qui nous fait un point sur
l'ensemble des lauréats pour nous dire
quelle est l'état des lieux cette note
est globalement très positive faisant
état de d'une bonne d'une bonne
exécution globalement de des des
différentes subventions il y a à ce
moment là une simple observation qui
fait qui fait une ligne dans cette note
indiquant qui pourrait y avoir un sujet
de contenu sur l'une des associations
sur laquelle j'imagine on reviendrai
également reconstruire le commun je
demande à ce moment-là plus
d'informations au secrétaire général du
cipdr qui nous indique que il avait vu
effectivement des contenus à caractère
politique qu'il avait convoqué les
responsables de la société qui avait dit
qu'évidemment ça ne se reproduirait plus
donc que l'affaire était close donc à ce
moment là c'est simplement il y a pas de
il y a pas d'alerte évidemment c'est
simplement des questions ou des
observations ensuite au mois de décembre
sur les questions d'un certain nombre de
journalistes insistantes sur la question
de la liste et du fait que elle n'est
pas rendue publique nous décidons de
transmettre un certain nombre de médias
donc en l'occurrence France 2 Marianne
et Mediapart nous décidons de montrer la
liste des lauréats à ces médias en
échange d'un engagement de ne pas la
diffuser pour maintenir la sécurité des
lauréats qui on le sait quand il s'agit
d'Islam radical sont très vite en
situation de risque donc au mois de
décembre nous montrons cette liste aux
différents médias et nous n'avons plus
de nouvelles sur le sujet jusqu'au 22
mars 22 mars date à laquelle donc nous
avons un
cabinet à un échange avec
France 2 de mémoire qui dit attention on
a
vu un problème sur une association
l'uspm qui visiblement n'a pas dépensé
correctement la subvention cette alerte
en fait est suivie dès le lendemain d'un
mail des nouveaux dirigeants de l'uspm
qui nous dit attention nous on a
constaté un problème dans dans la
manière dont cette subvention était
dépensée donc donc cette alerte nous
nous inquiète fortement et déclenche
ma demande d'une part de saisie de l'IGA
que nous faisons le lendemain et d'autre
part de demander aux préfets Gravel de
saisir la procureur de la République de
Paris sur le fondement de l'article 40
sur cette association
donc à la suite de ça donc le préfet
Gravel le fait le 31 mars il y a un
article 40 qui est qui est qui est fait
à la suite de ça donc
quelques jours à la suite de ça on
commence à comprendre qu'il y a qu'il y
aurait là encore une fois sur la base de
d'un certain temps d'informations des
journalistes des problèmes de contenu
qu'on avait commencé à identifier dans
le cadre de des premiers
questionsnements et donc je demande le
31 mars au secrétaire général du cipdr
de faire un travail de fond sur toutes
les associations et sur tous les
contenus pour regarder quelle est la
l'étendue de la problématique et si
effectivement les associations l'oréates
ont bien dépensé les subventions comme
il était prévu
on se rend compte très rapidement que il
y a un problème de contenu donc le 12
avril on se rend compte qu'il y a un
problème de contenu sur l'association
reconstruire le commun et donc nous
déclenchons je j'étends la mission de
l'IGA à l'ensemble des associations et
je décide de faire moi-même un article
un article 40 sur cette nouvelle
association voilà en gros pour le
calendrier je passe ensuite sur le le
parquet national financier qui une
information judiciaire le 4 mai et sur
la suite que vous connaissez bien
évidemment je voudrais simplement avant
de répondre à vos questions monsieur le
Président vous dire que la politique
publique en matière de lutte contre
l'islam radical c'est une politique
publique qui est absolument essentielle
dans le cadre de la lutte de contrôle
terrorisme qui est mené par le
gouvernement très clairement aujourd'hui
je l'ai dit encore dans le cadre d'une
réponse aujourd'hui les éléments de
renseignement que nous avons démontrent
que le le communautarisme le séparatisme
alimente la radicalisation qui elle met
qui elle-même pardon alimente le
terrorisme et là où avant les les
prêches les plus violents les plus
dangereux étaient faits dans les
mosquées ils sont aujourd'hui fait sur
les réseaux sociaux et donc on a besoin
de cette politique publique et cette
politique publique est menée en partie
bien évidemment par les services du
gouvernement mais on sait très bien que
les codes de ceux qui qui sont sur les
réseaux sociaux les méthodes les réseaux
eux-mêmes sont plus accessibles par un
de personnes de la société civile qui
sont mieux à même de répondre d'où
l'intérêt de la politique publique au
sens large qui est menée et donc on y
reviendra bien évidemment mais il y a
dans ce dossier de manière maintenant
très claire vu le rapport qui a été
remis par l'IGA des erreurs qui ont été
commises des fautes des manquements sur
lesquels on va revenir mais je pense
qu'il faut pas ça a été l'expression que
vous avez utilisé ce matin jeter le bébé
avec l'eau du bain il y a dans les dans
les associations qui ont été lauréates
comme dans d'autres qui travaillent dans
le cadre du FIPD dans le cadre de
partenariat avec le gouvernement des
associations qui font un travail
extraordinaire et qui en plus sont
depuis la publication par par un organe
de presse de la liste réellement
maintenant en insécurité menacée ils
nous ont répondu encore récemment suite
à un certain nombre de sollicitations
que il ne voulait plus y aller parce que
ils sont en danger donc je voudrais
simplement attirer votre attention pour
que dans les messages que nous passons
collectivement sur ce sujet on continue
de soutenir en tout cas ceux qui ceux
qui font ce travail de contrediscaux
républicains et de lutte contre l'islam
radical voilà monsieur le président
merci madame la ministre comme vous le
savez notre commission n'a pas du tout
pour objet de remettre en cause une
politique publique sur celle-ci ou tout
autre d'ailleurs ce n'est pas notre rôle
mais bien de voir comment elle est
exécutée dans les meilleures conditions
possibles et dans les le respect des
règles
qui sont fixés par ailleurs donc j'avais
donc quelques questions un peu générales
mais finalement où nous avez déjà
répondu ainsi d'ailleurs que votre
directeur de cabinet que je salue à vos
côtés
sur ce point et notamment sur le fait
que ce que je comprends bien d'ailleurs
étant élu de nouvelles Calédonie et à
l'époque ayant finalement peu de lien
avec la métropole enfin
sinon des liens évidemment des liaisons
indirectes
cet objet et vous pouvez vous être
inconnu même si on s'en est étonné quand
cela nous a été dit à la fois par le
directeur de cabinet et donc par
vous-même on peut s'étonner en tout cas
qu'elle ne figure pas et on y reviendra
dans simplement la continuité de
l'action de l'État c'est un point qui
est à mon avis et tout à fait essentiel
avez-vous quand même eu des pas une
discussion des contacts avec votre
collègue Marlène je sais pas sur ce
sujet que ce soit
au moment où vous arrivez elle aurait pu
éventuellement sans vous transmettre un
dossier en tout cas évoquer ce sujet ou
que ce soit depuis qu'il y a eu un
certain nombre de difficultés qui sont
apparues est-ce qu'il y a eu un échange
sur cette question et est-ce que cette
est-ce que vous pourriez nous dire de
s'il a eu lieu ou pas sur quoi il aurait
porté maintenant absolument pas de
discussion sur ce sujet
avant que l'affaire que l'affaire éclate
ensuite nous avons eu une discussion sur
le sujet dans laquelle je lui ai indiqué
que il était bon d'attendre les
résultats d'une part de l'IGA puisque
c'était avant la le résultat de la
mission de l'igéa d'autre part de la
Commission d'enquête et pour finir de la
justice avant de nous exprimer
publiquement sur le sujet voilà très
bien
alors nous avons eu une réponse de votre
de votre voisin qui est une réponse
assez claire sur le rôle du cabinet la
procédure sur lequel il y a eu de la
part du directeur de cabinet une
position très claire sur le fait qu'il
était pas anormal que finalement
le cabinet soit dans le
dans le système de décision de
sur l'attribution de fonds et plus
exactement sur la validation pour dire
les choses avec un terme plus plus
précis
des sujets on voit bien que dans cette
affaire là peut-être parce que c'était
aussi le démarrage c'est le cpdr avait
été finalement sur un fonctionnement un
peu autonome et lorsque le poste de
ministre délégué d'abord
et créer on revient un peu dans un cadre
un peu plus traditionnel et donc on a un
système de validation qui est qui
apparaît donc vous l'avez poursuivi
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire si de
déjà de des événements qui qui entourent
le fond Marianne des questions qui sont
posées est-ce que vous en tirez quelques
conclusions sur la manière de d'établir
cette relation entre l'administration le
cabinet vous-même
alors je pense que le processus tel
qu'il est construit c'est-à-dire là où
l'administration instruit et propose et
le politique finalement valide me paraît
parfaitement conforme je suis
accessoirement présidente de
collectivités locales c'est aussi comme
ça que ça se passe dans les
collectivités locales ça ne me paraît
pas
dissonant ou dysfonctionnant donc après
la question est de savoir quels sont les
contrôles a priori et à posteriori qui
sont effectués
là ce qu'on voit dans la dans le rapport
de la mission
IgA qui a été faite c'est que peut-être
il a manqué de contrôle notamment à
priori au moins sur une association et
que les contrôles a postériori montrent
un certain nombre de dysfonctionnements
et c'est je pense là-dessus que que nous
allons travailler
a priori
durant l'opération et la postériori un
peu il y a un peu l'ensemble dans le
rapport IgA si on le décode bien il y a
à peu près toutes les étapes qui sont
signalées
[Musique]
en tout cas c'est une effectivement
c'est un sujet prégnant que la question
de savoir comment on doit fonctionner
l'exemple qui a été donné à juste titre
votre directeur de cabinet c'est quand
on reçoit un dossier on reçoit toujours
quel que soit les rôles les
responsabilités que l'on a soit
municipales départementales régionales
ou ministériel c'est pareil on reçoit
des dossiers en direct et la règle qui
doit effectivement
s'appliquer c'est une règle de
transmission administration
sans éléments d'appréciation
particuliers laisser l'administration
travailler et voir après comment on peut
on peut avancer et peut-être que sur ces
pratiques-là qui paraissent de bon sens
et en plus qui mettent chacun dans ses
responsabilités clairement y a-t-il
peut-être à aller plus loin sur
peut-être l'écriture de quelque chose
sur dans le domaine vous voyez parce que
finalement le Duflou des fois sortent
des positions particulières le 10
octobre 2022 le préfet Gravel vous fait
parvenir une note dans laquelle il
explique les réseaux pour lesquelles la
liste de L'Oréal n'a pas été rendue
publique et pour lesquels une démarche a
été engagée pour ne pas les mentionner
dans le jaune budgétaire sur le soutien
de l'État aux associations il est fait
mention dans cette note d'une demande sa
réponse à une demande de la presse pour
obtenir la liste des lauréats
pouvez-vous nous rappeler ce contexte et
comment cette demande de notes est
formulée elle répond à quoi une demande
de votre part
effectivement nous sommes sollicités à
ce moment-là par
des médias c'est à ce moment c'est
plutôt plus tard quand on est sollicité
par des médias qui nous demandent la
liste et donc non à ce moment là pardon
excusez-moi ça vient en décembre la
demande de liste à ce moment-là on voit
simplement l'article du 30 juin qui dit
que la liste est tenue confidentiel et
ça a l'air de poser problème donc c'est
à ce moment là que je demande des
informations et qu'effectivement le
préfet Gravel nous indique que pour des
raisons de sécurité et dans un cadre qui
effectivement bien défini il est
la liste de lauréats pardon et garder
confidentiels et je pense que finalement
c'est quand même ce qui aurait dû être
fait à la fin finalement été transmise à
la finalement été rendue publique
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de lauréat
nous font part de menaces à leur
rencontre et je pense que dans la mesure
où ils sont directement en charge de
répondre à des discours
qui amènent à une forme de séparatisme
ils sont en danger et donc c'est la
volonté je crois du gouvernement et qui
était qui était partagée à l'époque de
garder cette liste confidentielle
merci Madame j'ai revenir sur un certain
nombre de faits
chronologiques comme vous les avez
évoqué dans votre propre introductif
heureusement j'ai pris des notes mais je
ne suis pas encore
un parfait pratiquant de l'asténo donc
il doit me manquer quelques petits
éléments mais je pense qu'on va être
assez près dans tous les cas de ce que
des éléments dont je dispose je vais
d'abord donc avoir confirmation et vous
l'avez dit au début de votre propre
objectif
que peu de temps après votre nomination
globalement
vous avez reçu une note avez-vous dit en
septembre
octobre
vous voyez hop
ou globalement était mentionné
la bonne exécution des subventions à
part une association vous l'avez cité
reconstruire le commun sur laquelle il y
avait des questions portant sur le ou
les contenus et assez rapidement le
secrétaire général du cpdr est intervenu
et que la situation
était réglée donc vous avez les
informations
vous les avez eu parce que j'essaie de
j'essaie de garder la tête froide par
rapport à ce matin
puisque ça veut dire que vous
vous produit une note donc c'est le
cabinet je pense le sgcipdr
qui passe au ministre le tout dans un
temps très court
j'en conclus une première chose c'est
que les rouages sont parfaitement huilés
votre arrivée n'a rien changé c'était la
pratique hier c'est la pratique
aujourd'hui et je dirais dans un mystère
ce sera la même pratique demain la
pratique de quoi de transmission du
ssjpdr au cabinet au ministre je suppose
en tout cas chez dans
des fluidité donc vous n'avez pas donné
de consignes particulières remettant en
cause le fonctionnement passé
sur le sujet de demander une note et
qu'elle soit transmise non je vois pas
pourquoi j'en aurais donné je vais vous
le dire pourquoi je m'interroge tout de
suite parce que comme vous l'avez dit à
plusieurs reprises et comme ce matin en
permanence
il y a eu votre prédécesseur expliquait
que elle n'avait pas connaissance
c'était le
cpdr le secrétaire général c'était le
cabinet mais elle n'était pas là même si
des membres du cabinet venaient du
cpdr avant voilà donc je veux ok
le bon fonctionnement ça me paraît assez
cohérent ça me paraît d'autant plus
cohérent que vous l'avez dit à plusieurs
reprises dans votre cours propose
productif donc
les choses sont assez objectives
deuxièmement vous nous avez je voulais
parler de la subvention la plus
importante et vous y êtes venu un peu
après sur l'USSE ppm qui effectivement
avait bénéficié d'une subvention
importante et qui ne répondait pas
depuis quelques temps déjà puisque
normalement historiquement quand les
subventions étaient accordées il va y
avoir un point au bout de six mois et de
novembre 2022 à février 2023 il y a eu
des relances et il y avait plus âme qui
vivent en tous les cas pas de réponse
donc vous avez bien là à nouveau été
averti de la situation est-ce que vous
savez à quel moment
et par qui je pense que c'est là aussi
par le cpdr alors d'abord je précise je
comprends le sens de votre question je
ne suis évidemment pas informé de tout
ce qui se passe à l'intérieur du sgcipdr
c'est absolument pas mon rôle je pense
que ce serait un problème si c'était le
cas donc toute la partie administrative
du suivi je ne l'ai absolument pas par
contre évidemment je suis informé de ce
que fait mon cabinet qui lui a des
réunions régulières avec le secrétariat
général du cipdr d'une part pour
transmettre l'impulsion politique que je
souhaite transmettre et d'autre part
pour recueillir de la part du sgcipdr
d'éventuelles problématiques qui se
poseraient ou les avancées des dossiers
qui leur ont été confiés donc j'ai
effectivement je pense que ça doit être
dans le courant du mois de mars j'ai pas
le j'ai pas le la date exacte le la
remontée par le
lgcipdr pardon et mon cabinet du fait
qu'on a un souci de transmission de
documents par l'useppm ce qui amène de
de façon à à la suite c'est à dire à la
mission qui est confiée à l'igéa et à
l'article 40 parce que effectivement il
ne transmettent pas les documents d'une
part et puis effectivement on n'a aucune
réponse de leur part et puis je ça
termine avec le 23 mars je sais pas si
vous l'aviez noté mais le les nouveaux
les nouveaux responsables de
l'association qui nous disent que
visiblement il y a un problème voilà
c'est ça donc vous êtes plutôt
alerté avec les warnings en mars 2023
puisque la situation a perdurer malgré
des relances ce qui très clairement
parfait
j'avais noté 22 il me semblait que c'est
48 heures après mais on va pas chipoter
donc le finalement pour les deux
associations reconstruire le commun et
l'uspm
vous n'avez pas eu les mêmes enfin vous
avez des alertes mais pas au même moment
et
est-ce que c'était selon vous à chaque
fois avant des annonces faites par la
presse
ou après c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce que des
éléments avaient été communiqués les
aviez pas forcément vous n'aviez pas
forcément connaissance mais ce qu'ils
étaient déjà dans le circuit faites les
deux c'est à dire qu'en fait il y a deux
situations différentes celle de l'uspm
ou
l'alerte principale vient quand même du
mail qu'on reçoit des nouveaux gouver
des nouveaux dirigeants de l'association
qu'il a clairement nous nous inquiète
au-delà de la question de la presse
c'est ça qui nous génère le le la grosse
alerte sur la question de reconstruire
le commun c'était au départ juste un
questionnement qui en plus avait été
balayé puisque réglé puisque c'était un
questionnement dans la note du mois
d'octobre sur il y avait un problème de
contenu il a fait un je crois que
c'était un contenu politique contraire
exemmour on l'a convoqué pour lui dire
qu'il y avait pas de contenu politique à
avoir et les choses ont été recadrées le
la vraie problématique vient là
effectivement par des questions de la
presse qui nous dit simplement qui ne
cite pas d'associations qui nous dit
simplement
on a commencé à regarder sur la base de
la liste que vous nous avez montré et il
semble qu'il y a des problèmes de
contenu qui génèrent le 31 mars de ma
part une demande via mon cabinet
évidemment
osg.c.i PDR de décortiquer tous les
contenus donc ils ont regardé des heures
et des heures de contenu pour nous faire
une note qui amène à la grosse alerte
sur la deuxième association reconstruire
le commun avec des contenus d'ordre
politique qui vont bien au-delà de ce
qui avait été observé au mois d'octobre
voilà donc la presse en partie et puis
le travail de contrôle
d'autre part donc je peux en conclure là
encore que
l'information est fluide
elle vous enfin les warnings elles vous
remontent
normalement sans obstacle et de la même
manière
vous prenez des décisions vous donner
des directives elles sont mises en
oeuvre sous votre autorité par le
cabinet et évidemment par l'opérateur de
ces PDF
pour moi en tous les cas c'est ça paraît
parfaitement clair simple et je dirais
je le redis beaucoup plus limpide que ce
que nous avons entendu ce matin
peut-être sur ce point pour
selon les éléments qu'on vous a donné
dans les différentes notes évidemment
mais on a une difficulté là de
présentation de ce qui était ce qui a
été fait
par le Secrétariat général
par rapport à ses contenus
il y a deux lectures on a deux versions
si je puis dire donc si par hasard vous
avez non pas une troisième ça nous
aiderait pas mais une des deux
privilégiée ça serait bien
pour bien rappeler le contexte le préfet
de Gravel nous a indiqué ici
qu'il avait fait des diligences dès
qu'il avait vu les contenus
un peu particuliers on va dire sans
exagérer des choses non plus mais un peu
particulier mettant en cause des
personnalités politiques dont on peut se
demander que si on veut faire la défense
des valeurs républicaines je suis pas
sûr qu'il faille démarrer par une
agression tous azimut sur les élus de
toute tendance je suis pas tout à fait
sûr mais enfin je pense que vous
partagez à peu près cette idée mais le
préfet Gravel nous a dit voilà
j'ai fait
comment dire j'ai reçu l'association je
lui ai indiqué que c'était pas
admissible etc
quand on reçoit l'association la prière
de l'association
ne s'en souvient pas
en tout cas ça a pas marqué aujourd'hui
on en a pas
c'est pas du tout d'un coup je pense que
ça me souviendrait mais elle dit
simplement j'ai eu une remarque par
rapport au fait qu'on ait fait référence
au président de la République à Emmanuel
Macron dans une des séquences que la
réalité parmi les séquences et donc il y
a eu une mise en cause plutôt sur ça
c'est à dire pourquoi enfin n'utilisez
plus à Macron d'autre part
lorsqu'il y a ce type de problème dans
une association on pourrait s'attendre à
ce que à ce que l'administration fasse
un écrit
bon on peut par oral dire il y a un
souci alors donc on a deux versions un
petit peu sur les contenus mis en avant
l'un n'interdit pas l'autre on peut
parler d'une question sur le président
de la République depuis d'autres trucs
mais l'association elle nous dit on nous
a dit en gros voilà ne faites plus ça
bon très bien et c'est tout et surtout
il n'y a pas eu un seul écrit
la mise une mise en garde généralement
quand il y a un problème avec
quelqu'un avec lequel on travaille ça
peut prendre une forme écrite ça reste
dans le dossier
voilà donc est-ce que vous là dessus il
y avait il y avait dans les notes que
vous avez eu des éléments particuliers
sur ce sujet qui nous permettrait de
choisir une des deux versions
malheureusement monsieur le Président je
vais pas pouvoir vous aider parce que ça
s'est passé avant que j'arrive je n'ai
absolument aucun élément si ce n'est
ceux qui sont arrivés après donc je vais
pas pouvoir trancher ce sujet là je ne
sais pas quelle est la version qu'il
vous faudra garder j'en suis navré
parfait merci
décidément pardon est-ce que vous avez
pour habitude et pratique d'entretenir
avec les partenaires associatifs
qui interviennent sur le sujet du contre
discours des relations
de suivi régulier qui vous permettent à
la fois d'apprécier la qualité du
travail fournie voire de réorienter
quelle est la pratique sous votre
autorité en tout cas
non je ne le fais pas parce que je
considère que ce n'est pas mon rôle ce
n'est pas le rôle du ministre le rôle du
ministre c'est d'impulser une politique
c'est de
d'initier et de effectivement faire le
point de manière régulière avec
l'administration qui est en charge du
suivi pour savoir si effectivement les
choses sont faites correctement dans le
cadre des objectifs politiques qui ont
été fixés je vais je vais vous permettre
de vous donner un exemple de d'une
politique publique que je porte qui est
la lutte contre les dérives sectaires
pour lesquels pour laquelle on a confié
c'est le sgcipdr également dans le cadre
de la mi-vilud en particulier qui s'en
occupe on a de la même manière confiée
au secrétariat général du cipdr une
politique publique à mettre en oeuvre et
on fait un point via mon cabinet de
manière régulière avec le sgcipdr pour
savoir comment les choses avancent et
c'est le sgcipdr qui fait lui-même le
point avec les associations il nous
arrive bien évidemment de recevoir des
associations dans les dans le cadre des
politiques publiques qu'on mène pour non
pas pour faire le point sur leur action
mais pour voir avec elle quels sont les
points qui avancent qui n'avancent enfin
qui qui qu'on souhaite faire avancer
comment elle le voit et comment comment
elle sentent la situation voilà donc
globalement comme vous l'avez dit mais
je
veux bien m'en assurer vous avez des
notes
qui sont demandés ou envoyés intervalles
réguliers qui vous font un peu un état
de la situation vous avez eu un moment
une alerte donc c'est l'administration
aussi PDR qui reçoit des consignes de la
part du ministre ou du cabinet pour
veiller à comment dire rectifier ce qui
est éventuellement ne fonctionne pas
soit des notes soit des réunions de
points réguliers très bien je veux
revenir un tout petit peu puisque vous
[Musique]
comment dirais-je vous embrasser une
nouvelle responsabilité ministérielle
vous l'avez dit sur un sujet qui vous
est étrangers vous avouez que c'est pas
non plus celui auquel je me
m'intéresse en premier
en fait
est-ce que le les conditions de cet
appel à projet
est-ce que vous êtes un moment fait
expliquer de quelle manière ce
dispositif avait été mis en oeuvre je
rappelle qu'il a été quand même mis en
œuvre
dans un temps très court avec une
procédure assez lâche c'est à dire avec
peu de rigueur en termes de méthode en
termes de d'exécution c'est-à-dire de du
contenu de notation et
de transmission de l'information
à celle des associations qui avaient
candidatées est-ce que vous avez par
rapport à cet état de fait une remarque
ou des souhaits exprimés pour l'avenir
alors avant les alertes je n'ai eu
aucune connaissance de la manière dont
cet appel à projet a été lancé bien
évidemment depuis je
lis et j'ai lu avec attention le rapport
de l'IGA qui démontre clairement qu'il y
a eu des erreurs voire peut-être des
fautes en tout cas un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements majeur qui doivent
nous amener à faire évoluer les méthodes
pour ce qui pour ce qui concerne le les
autres appels à projets qui ont été
lancés par le Secrétariat général du CPD
on a lancé deux appels à projets en
matière de lutte contre les dérives
sectaires l'ensemble des contrôles ont
été effectués a été effectués pardon a
postérieux a priori pardon et le a
postériori ou en tout cas le reste est
en cours dans un délai aussi court avec
je dirais les
contrôles aussi rapides ou succinct
je crois que la situation est
complètement différente sur les appels à
projets voilà moi je porte pas de
jugement sur ce qui s'est passé avant la
situation et le choc qu'a connu la
France suite à l'attentat de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine a amené sans
doute à des décisions différentes que la
question de la lutte contre les dérives
sectaires qui est une politique publique
de long terme et qui est sans doute pas
qui qui pose sans doute pas les mêmes
urgences donc je porte aucun jugement
sur la manière dont les choses se sont
passées je crois que simplement il y a
un certain nombre de de conclusion
attirer et d'adaptation à faire
absolument indispensable suite à d'une
part ce premier rapport de l'igé mais on
en aura un deuxième qui nous donnera et
et les conclusions de votre commission
qui nous donneront quand même un cadre
qui nous permettra de faire mieux
les prochaines fois
j'entends ce que vous venez de nous
communiquer ceci étant
je crois pas qu'il y ait
un rapport aussi différent que celui que
vous évoquez au regard de la gravité de
l'événement qui a donné lieu à la
création du fond puisque ce qu'on
observe c'est finalement les premiers
éléments
portés en audition par l'administration
c'est dire normalement il faut deux à
trois mois et puis c'est il y a une
accélération soudaine dont on n'arrive
pas complètement à comprendre qui décide
de décide pas regarde regarde pas voilà
c'était la raison pour laquelle je
voulais avoir cet élément alors vous
nous avez évoqué le mail du 24 mars
le projet de signalement au sujet des
associations du fond Marianne la
décision de faire le signalement c'est
vous qui l'a proposé qu'il apprenait
c'est moi qui la prend et mon cabinet
qui la met en œuvre
on a une procédure de contrôle
d'ailleurs en cours vous avez évoqué
l'autre association reconstruire le
commun qui
pourrait donner lieu à une demande de
remboursement ça nous a été confirmé
lors de l'audition en présence des
membres de l'association ça a été fait
au début du mois de mai est-ce que vous
avez
participé à la décision
dans quel sens j'imagine que si vous
avez participé c'est certainement pour
confirmer puisque est-ce que vous n'avez
pas le sentiment que cette décision est
un peu
tardive je veux dire par là qu'il
s'avère qu'elle intervient
consécutivement de nouvelles révélations
par la presse donc y a-t-il
peut-on conclure qui a comme un lien de
cause effets ou absolument pas
par des éléments que vous pourriez nous
communiquer
on peut pas on peut pas effectivement
dire qu'il y a pas de lien de cause à
effet clairement la presse c'est
intéressé au sujet il n'y a pas que la
presse je l'ai dit pour lui seppm pour
la question des contenus on a demandé le
31 mars à regarder l'ensemble des
contenus de l'ensemble des associations
et c'est sur la base de ce travail-là
qui n'est pas celui exclusif fait par la
presse que nous avons effectivement été
alertés sur un certain nombre de contenu
qui n'avait rien à faire dans dans ce
dans dans l'objectif qui était qui était
fixé initialement donc
voilà la décision j'ai contribué je l'ai
prise elle a été mise en oeuvre compte
tenu de des éléments qui nous ont été
transmis par le Secrétariat général du
cipdr sur la base de du visionnage
d'heures de plusieurs heures de contenu
extrêmement lourd et qui ont donné lieu
à une identification précise de tous les
contenus qui posaient problème de
manière à ce qu'effectivement on puisse
avoir l'ampleur de la problématique ce
qui veut dire que vous considérez qu'il
y a eu des subventions trop importantes
versées et qu'on regarde ce qui a été
versé il est logique de
prétendre à remboursement d'accord
l'igéa dans son rapport
préconise ou recommande trois choses
donc l'émission du titre exécutoire d'un
peu plus de 127000 euros de prendre acte
des manquements aux obligations
statutaires qui ont été relevés par la
mission et enfin de compléter la saisine
du procureur de la République est-ce que
vous nous confirmez aujourd'hui vouloir
la mise en application des trois
recommandations de ce rapport de Ligue 1
alors oui la première est déjà en cours
de mise en oeuvre puisque la procédure
contradictoire a été initiée par le
Secrétariat général du cipdr sur la mise
en œuvre des poursuites disciplinaires
ce sera
mis en oeuvre mais nous attendons le
deuxième rapport de manière à avoir une
vision globale de la situation et pour
le complément arctique 40 il relève de
l'igéa puisque ce sont eux qui ont la
connaissance et la vision globale sur le
sujet
donc oui sur les trois préconisations
merci on va poursuivre on va assez vite
puisque effectivement
votre relation au projet et relativement
limité dans le temps on va dire ça comme
ça donc on va on va assez vite et on va
plutôt vers aujourd'hui les prospectives
les recommandations alors
un sujet que nous avons que nous
évoquons qui est un sujet
pas si simple que ça c'est la relation
quand on travaille
et que l'on confie à des associations
une fonction
mais comment dire sans tout en laissant
à l'association le soin de mettre en
œuvre
la question c'est jusqu'au on va dans le
dispositif alors en ce qui vous concerne
c'est plutôt une réflexion prospective
que je vous demande d'une certaine façon
vous avez vous auriez demain à faire à
poursuivre vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
c'est une politique publique qui a des
chances qu'elle se poursuivent enfin en
tout cas
on espère que cela pourra être fait et
donc
les quand on va un peu loin il y a deux
choses la première chose c'est que
souvent dans ces et c'est un vrai
problème on a monté des des projets qui
sont des faux projets je fais simple
c'est à dire
on associe à des montants de subventions
d'autres subventions ou des fonds privés
sur lesquels on a d'ailleurs aucune
trace c'est-à-dire non seulement on n'a
pas on a des réponses négatives sans
doute mais on n'est même pas sûr qu'il y
a eu des questions est-ce que je veux
dire c'est à dire que les fonds demandés
ont-ils été sollicité on n'en sait rien
et on se demande et pourquoi ça a été
monté comme ça c'est pour dire que après
le fond Marianne il y avait l'idée qu'il
y avait un relais par d'autres
financements que ceux
de l'État dans la réalité que dans les
deux en particulier dans les deux
groupes projets
initiés à ce moment-là
il y avait des sommes
bien sûr que une des fautes c'est de pas
avoir vérifié avant de démarrer le
projet qu'il y avait au moins eu des
demandes dans ce sens pas toujours tout
obtenir avant de démarrer mais au moins
que les demandes étaient formulées de
financement ce n'était pas le cas mais
de manière générale on a une question
qui est toujours d'un instant où le
l'État et le non seulement le premier
financeur mais en fait le financeur
unique dans beaucoup de projets de cette
nature on peut le comprendre parce que
le sujet n'appelle pas je veux dire des
soutiens privés massifs
de cette façon là quel est le lien qui
doit s'établir
entre entre l'association quel est le
niveau de contrôle qui est possible
et acceptable et qu'elle est finalement
la zone de de
ou l'association est libre un peu
d'avancer comment les choses peuvent
s'articuler vous savez qu'on a eu dans
nos dans nos auditions on a eu la
question alors ça a été évidemment
comment dire formuler de manière un peu
abrupte en disant on n'est pas des
sous-traitants
de ces PDR d'accord on n'est pas des
sous-traitants mais enfin on est financé
intégralement donc
comment vous imaginez cette ajustement
entre
avoir un financement public ne pas avoir
un contrôle total parce qu'il faut
laisser une part de liberté à
l'association mais on contrôle quand
même pour ne pas se retrouver dans des
situations ou ensuite on est appelé soit
à demander des remboursements soit
à finalement de finir par un article 40
ce qui n'est pas très heureux lorsqu'on
a lancé un projet
avec la
des 15 autres associations c'est à dire
qu'en fait cette politique publique elle
est capable d'être menée à bien de
manière tout à fait correcte on a fixé
un grand objectif qui était celui de
lutter contre les discours en matière
d'Islam radicale avec une destination
qui était principalement les jeunes de
12 à 25 ans donc ce grand objectif là
les associations évidemment le
connaissait et avait l'obligation de
produire des contenus de de faire du
contre discours sur sur ce public là
avec cet objectif là et on se rend
compte que les associations la plupart
des associations d'une part lauréate du
fond Marianne d'autre part qui
travaillent aujourd'hui avec avec l'État
dans le cas notamment du FIPD savent
très bien ce qu'elles peuvent faire ce
qu'elles doivent faire tout en étant pas
des des salariés du gouvernement c'est
toute la difficulté de l'exercice mais
qui finalement n'en est pas réellement
une quand on voit finalement le la
production qui est faite par un certain
nombre d'associations et la réussite
finalement de de cette mission là donc
sur la question de savoir s'il doit y
avoir s'il peut y avoir d'autres
financeurs je ne crois pas je crois que
cette politique publique malheureusement
ne peut être mener que parler l'État et
doit être mené par l'État mais par
contre les services de l'État tel qu'ils
sont construits ne peuvent pas seuls
assumer cette mission de contrediscours
parce que bien évidemment on voit bien
que les moyens ont changé les publics
ont changé ont évolué et que la société
civile et un certain nombre de
structures associatives le font mieux
donc je pense qu'on doit pouvoir
continuer tout en assurant des contrôles
à priori plus important que ce qui a été
fait tout en assurant un contrôle au fur
et à mesure et à posteriori mais je
crois profondément dans le fait que on
peut mener cette politique publique sous
cette forme là en associant la société
civile et en vérifiant évidemment de
manière de manière continue si il n'y a
pas de dérive en matière de contenu
c'est ce qu'on a vu sur sur une
association et si l'association met bien
en oeuvre ce pourquoi elle a été
subventionnée mais je ne vois pas de
difficultés majeure je pense qu'il faut
pas encore une fois il y a eu là on le
voit bien des erreurs des
dysfonctionnements mais je ne crois pas
que ce soit la politique publique dans
son ensemble et le fait de de s'appuyer
sur le tissu associatif qui soit à
revoir
je vous entends madame la ministre
parler de réussite des 15 autres projets
il faut peut-être l'Union c'est quand
même dans la mesure où vous avez 10
projets qui en réalité
sont des projets d'association avec
lequel le CPL travaille depuis 5 ans
et donc que après 5 ans de travail avec
avec une structure de l'État une
administration de l'État liée
une pratique un discours une pratique
qui se soit affinée au cours du temps
qui fait que ces associations maintenant
réussissent ou en tout cas ont des
éléments de visibles de travail de rendu
de relations avec le cyprideur qui soit
convenable qui soit correctement menée
oui mais il se trouve que le la question
se pose lorsqu'il s'agit
vraiment à la fois de nouveaux projets
et de nouvelles structures et c'est là
qu'en fait les choses pêchent pour
beaucoup c'est à dire que quand on
travaille avec de nouveaux acteurs qui
plus aient des nouveaux acteurs portés
par des associations soit naissantes
soit très faibles
la question de la relation est
extrêmement doit être extrêmement
travaillé en tout cas si elle ne leçon
qu'on doit tirer me semble-t-il de cette
expérience c'est que effectivement
lorsqu'on a un nouvel acteur il faut
l'accompagner pour utiliser un
vocabulaire
moderne on accompagne tout aujourd'hui
bon mais donc en tout cas
il y a quelque chose autour de autour de
autour de ce sujet pour ça qu'on faut
relativiser si je puis dire
la réussite globale d'autre part si vous
voulez les autres associations pour
l'essentiel et des associations qui
travaillaient un peu sur la notion de la
fraternité je veux au sens large c'est à
dire
50 tweets et 200 vues bon on sait qu'on
a loupé tout mais même si on a un
million de tweets et des millions de
vues on n'est pas sûr que ce soit vu par
ce que l'on souhaite atteindre donc il y
a aussi au delà de l'objectif qui peut
avoir du sens encore une fois on n'est
pas là en tout cas nous pour dire pour
commenter une politique publique moins
dans ce cadre là on peut le faire
ailleurs sur d'autres sujets mais pas
dans ce cadre donc une politique
publique est une chose mais encore
faut-il se donner les moyens de la
mesurer les impacts parce que on peut
pas se contenter uniquement de nombre de
vues si je voulais le dire de manière
plus encore plus plus direct je dirais
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux pas très peu de
très peu de Visio ou de vidéos etc bien
faites mais très vu et par les bons
[Musique]
du contenu qui arrive à faire passer des
messages qu'on n'arrive plus à faire
passer à un certain nombre de jeunes
parce qu'il n'écoute plus il n'écoute
pas
ni leurs enseignants ni finalement ce
qui est tout ce qui relève de l'État
donc c'est là où il faut réussir à faire
passer des messages avec des codes
différents avec des effectivement c'est
pas juste un film avec écrit pardon mais
République française parce que personne
ne va le regarder en tout cas ceux qui
pourraient être concernés
ministère de l'Intérieur en tout cas en
tout cas très clairement on va pas
toucher ceux qui sont susceptibles
d'être atteint par ces messages là donc
il nous faut vraiment se réinventer d'où
le fait et je voudrais revenir sur sur
votre intervention initiale sur la
question de des nouvelles associations
oui il faut les accompagner mais non il
faut pas les écarter parce que je pense
qu'on a besoin d'innovation on a besoin
de créativité et on a besoin de ces
nouveaux acteurs qui peut-être ont une
vision
différente de des jeunes publics et qui
sont capables peut-être d'adapter
également les contenus assez jeune
public
de manière générale et toujours pour en
tirer des leçons pour pour la suite
parce que nous c'est aussi ce que nous
souhaitons faire à la fin de notre
rapport Mario vous entendre sur
finalement au vu de ce que vous voyez de
ce dossier est-ce qu'il faudrait mieux
préciser les conditions dans lesquelles
des associations doivent mener les
projets
est-ce que des clauses de convention
d'attribution doivent être revues pour
exclure peut-être un certain nombre de
pratiques
ce qu'on a vu de manière générale c'est
que c'était
comment dire extrêmement léger
voilà vous on a le simplifie on a des
associations qui sont pas bâties pour
obtenir des grandes des subventions
importantes qu'un n'ont jamais eu
on a un système de contrôle défaillant
on a un système de mesure de résultats
inexistants et à la sortie évidemment
bah ça produit ce que ça produit voilà
et d'ailleurs pour les deux associations
en question ce sont des choses très
différentes d'ailleurs et des
problématiques très différentes je mets
pas du tout sur sur le même plan mais du
coup
même vous voyez quand on dit on va
on va demander un remboursement par
exemple
sur la base de quoi c'est à dire ça si
c'est sur la base de la convention
signée
la demande est en faible le comment dire
arriver à dire à justifier d'un
remboursement sur quelque chose qui
n'est pas demandé bon c'est un peu léger
donc est-ce que vous avez déjà un peu
travaillé sur cette question si d'autres
appels à projets par extraordinaire
devaient arriver oui clairement on a des
axes d'amélioration on a je pense que
plus on mieux on encadre les objectifs
qui sont fixés aux associations
l'oréates et mieux le contrôle peut se
faire
et en cours et a posteriori donc
effectivement plus on est précis dans
les objectifs qui sont fixés et mieux on
arrivera par la suite à le contrôler
donc je crois qu'effectivement de toute
façon cette cette opération va nous
amener avec les les deux rapports de la
mission de l'igéa à faire évoluer les
procédures de manière évidente et sur
les comités merci pour la réponse sur
les comités de sélection
avait noté dès ma première conférence de
presse sur le sujet le caractère
endogène du comité sélection qui m'avait
beaucoup beaucoup gêné je veux dire que
quand on fait un appel à projet
se retrouver avec trois membres du
cabinet et trois membres de
l'administration trois membres du
cabinet dont deux sont issus de
l'administration concerné bon ça fait ça
fait ça fait vraiment très endogène quoi
c'est ça fait entre soi quoi bon oui
voilà bon on parle entre bon et
peut-être qu'en quand on fait un appel à
projet peut-être qu'il est pas mauvais
d'avoir à ses côtés une ou deux
personnes
peut-être sur des compétences
différentes qui ne sont pas les
compétences finalement liées à l'action
menée mais qui sont plus liés sur
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux etc
on nous a dit d'ailleurs que le cpdr il
est une des deux personnes étaient
qualifiée enfin au final quand on
regardait le résultat quand on voit par
exemple les associations qui proposent
15 minutes
pour attirer des jeunes de 15 à 22 15
minutes sur sur Youtube ou je sais pas
quoi on est on est loin de la pratique
des jeunes quoi très très loin je vais
dire quand on est sur 10 minutes être
sûr qu'ils envoient pas 9 minutes 45 si
déjà il voit 15 secondes avant de fermer
la boîte c'est magnifique
donc
on peut quand même se dire que un peu de
un peu de vision par comment les jeunes
font aujourd'hui quelle pratique etc
n'aurait pas été inutile à la réflexion
donc sur ce caractère endogène vous vous
partagez cette idée vous pensez qu'il
faut aller que peut-être on peut ouvrir
un peu les choses ou est-ce que ça vous
paraît finalement tout à fait normal
l'oriente un peu la réponse j'ai
l'impression mais bon légèrement c'est
le président vous sous-estimez les
jeunes sur les 15 secondes d'abord
parce que moi je vois que les jeunes
quand ils me regardent c'est c'est
rarement qu'elle seconde
mon sentiment c'est qu'il faut pas non
plus exclure le politique je veux vous
dire c'est que je pense qu'effectivement
dans l'instruction dans les propositions
il doit y avoir les expertises dont vous
faites pas c'est à dire qu'effectivement
il doit remonter aux politiques dans le
processus de validation les éléments de
prise de décision qui disent ben voilà
telle association elle apporte telle et
telle
nouveauté telle ou telle proposition
importante et donc il doit il doit être
amené à la validation du politique les
éléments effectivement concrets ensuite
le processus moi je crois qu'à un moment
donné il y a un rôle du politique à la
fin dans le processus de validation
vous savez vous êtes vous êtes vend des
élus ici en attendant à penser que le
politique a un rôle voilà manière
générale donc on ne méconnait pas ce
point mais pour autant
lorsqu'on cherche un peu de l'innovation
et c'est pas mauvais de s'entourer
je pense
c'est certainement consubstantiel à la
rapidité
c'est à dire le dépôt de candidature est
clair 20 jours
donc je pense que certains ont pensé
qu'il fallait aller vite et quand le
président rénal parle de
comment dirais-je un peu d'entre soi
comme en plus au cabinet il y avait deux
ou trois membres qui venaient du cpdr
qui était au cabinet qu'on est en termes
d'ouverture
c'est relativement limité et je
nous invite parce que je
me suis replongé dedans à regarder vous
verrez par rapport aux éditions
auxquelles on procède il est toujours en
ligne
l'appel à projet pour Marianne publié le
20 avril 21 sur le secrétariat général
du cpdr vous verrez par rapport aux
éléments qu'on évoque aujourd'hui il y a
quand même
un certain nombre de trous ou de manque
voilà
alors vous avez déjà répondu à la
question suivante vous êtes en avant de
phase dans béton pour ma question mais
je vais vous y faire revenir d'un mot
vous avez d'ailleurs
euh raison de manière générale vous
dites lorsqu'on veut chercher des
systèmes innovants il faut pas
s'interdire de prendre des des de de
d'avoir des créations certaines façons
bon et on peut imaginer que sur des
choses qui existent pas il faut
presque
accepter en tout cas que des acteurs
nouveaux
sans passer
sans histoire
associatif puissent répondre
c'est ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure et c'est sans doute vrai mais
encore faut-il et vous la vidéo aussi
mais je voudrais réinsister dans ces cas
très très précis le suivi doit être
extrêmement précis voilà c'est ça que je
veux dire sinon on en arrive de
l'expérimental pur bon
il en faut un peu on peut mais en même
temps il faut pas qu'à la sortie ça
tourne ça tourne à une dérive voilà donc
sur ce point je pense que on est
d'accord je partage votre
avisé tenez voilà je vous donne 300 000
débrouillez-vous et on se revoit à la
fin pour voir si tout va bien
un peu léger et en tout cas ça la ça
l'expérimentation parce que c'était
vraiment une phase un peu expérimentale
ces deux associations l'a bien la bien
démontré
enfin on regarde les événements et je me
permets simplement de vous de vous
donner la parole pour une conclusion
en quelques mots regardez l'événements
quels sont les évolutions que vous
envisagez d'ores et déjà de prendre en
compte rapport de l'IGA ou pas je veux
dire vous êtes suffisamment bien entouré
et vous avez suffisamment de gens autour
de vous pour et vous-même pour
effectivement
voir un peu comment comment mieux cadrer
les choses parce que ce qu'il faudrait
pas c'est que évidemment
au cours suivant si je puis dire on
recommence et qu'on retombe dans le même
type des romans quoi voilà
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement je pense que de toute
façon cette affaire nous amènera à un
certain nombre d'évolution d'évolution
dans la manière dont sont accordées les
subventions avec la question des
contrôles à priori qui sans doute ont
été insuffisants dans l'affaire dont on
parle sur la manière et je crois que
c'est un élément important que vous avez
évoqué la manière dont on accompagne au
fur et à mesure les associations pour
voir si effectivement dans le cadre de
du grand objectif de politique publique
qui est donné les choses vont dans le
bon sens sans être dans dans un contrôle
trop proche ou les associations
deviendraient des prestataires pur et
simple de du gouvernement mais en tout
cas il y a effectivement des moyens à
donner pour assurer ce contrôle a priori
en cours et à posteriori ça fait partie
du travail que nous nous devons mener
au-delà de ça je le répète de manière
très courte je tiens à ce que cette
politique publique qui est menée puisse
continuer et qu'elle ne soit pas
entachée par les erreurs qui sont
constatées les fautes qui seront sans
doute sanctionnés dans les dans les
prochaines semaines parce que je le
répète cette politique publique elle est
absolument essentielle on le voit sur la
question de la laïcité à l'école pour ne
prendre que cet exemple là que je vous
ai donné tout à l'heure où on a des
réseaux extrêmement puissants qui
touchent nos jeunes et si on n'est pas
en capacité d'avoir du contredisco ce
qu'on appelle alors c'est peut-être
maladroit mais du contrediscours
républicain on se on sera pas en
capacité de lutter contre ça et c'est
bien ces messages là qui génèrent la
radicalisation et derrière
malheureusement le terrorisme donc
vraiment je pense que cette politique
publique doit être continuée et oui il y
a eu visiblement des erreurs et elle ne
doivent pas emmener l'ensemble de la
politique publique ensuite et pour finir
vous dire que le secrétariat général du
cipdr est une organisation qui a gros
avec le temps en fonction des
problématiques et que j'ai missionné le
3 février dernier donc totalement en
décalage et en avec aucun lien avec la
question du fond Marianne qui est
arrivée après l'inspection générale de
l'administration pour me faire des
propositions en matière de
réorganisation du secrétariat général du
cipdr parce que effectivement ça a
grossi il y a eu des missions en plus on
a la question des mineurs autour de
zones qui est arrivée etc etc et donc on
a besoin de cette réorganisation et donc
je crois que dans le cadre de cette
réorganisation plus globale qui est
encore une fois n'est pas forcément en
lien que avec la question du fond
Marianne les travaux de l'IGA sur cette
réorganisation les travaux de l'IGA sur
les questions particulières du fond
Marianne et les résultats de votre
commission d'enquête nous amènerons sans
doute à avoir des procédures plus
solides pour l'avenir pour je le répète
continuer cette politique publique
merci alors nous avons quelques
collègues peut-être qu'ils souhaitent
dire un mot Jérôme Bacher
merci j'ai le président pour cette
question qui est
liée à une vieille pratique
administrative qui était la mienne
il me semblait que lorsqu'on écrivait au
ministre on écrivait à l'époque j'étais
avoir bien avant que le mail soit autant
répandu le téléphone et le WhatsApp soit
autant répandu on écrivait une note au
ministre ça s'écrivait comme cela dans
l'administration française sous couvert
du directeur de cabinet sous couvert du
directeur d'administration centrale
histoire de faire valider un certain
nombre d'éléments est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
cette pratique est encore la même et
c'est comme cela que vous validez par
exemple les subventions parce qu'à la
fin il faut bien arrêter ministériel les
subventions ou est-ce que c'est du mail
au fur et à mesure et c'est fait comme
cela
c'est un peu plus où ça reste informel
c'est chose que j'aimerais avoir
un peu clairement ma vieille pratique
administrative c'était un peu différent
la pratique je voudrais vérifier qu'il
n'y a pas d'autres demandes collègues si
Monsieur Breuillet Daniel broyer et vous
aussi Arnaud vous répondrez vers
l'ensemble si vous voulez bien merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je comprends et je partage par ailleurs
votre souhait que la politique publique
perdure est-ce que selon vous cette
politique que vous avez aujourd'hui une
stratégie pour la mettre en oeuvre
suffisamment pensé c'est à dire par
exemple est-ce que des universités ont
travaillé à vos côtés pour se demander
comment on pénètre sur les réseaux
sociaux est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut une diversité d'intervenants
d'associations ou plutôt des gens très
homogènes c'est pour moi une grande
interrogation parce que les valeurs de
la République sont un bien commun et je
me suis interrogé sur le fait qu'on
choisisse qu'on choisisse pas est-ce
qu'un vivier est-ce que pour vous par
exemple la diversité des formes
d'intervention des méthodes
d'intervention sur le net et est un
sujet que vous retenez ou bien qui est
en travail en tous les cas voilà est-ce
qu'il y a des changements de ce point de
vue en termes de stratégie pour pénétrer
dans les réseaux sociaux
une seule président ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général
j'ai participé ce matin à l'audition de
Madame Chapat et je sens deux ambiances
de travail différente
et je ne suis pas là pour apprécier
l'une et l'autre mais elles sont
totalement différentes et ce que je
crois comprendre c'est que vous avez
remis un peu d'ordre dans tous les cas
vous l'avez vous avez la volonté de
remettre de l'ordre dans les pratiques
au sein de votre ministère et vous nous
avez donné quelques indices et je crois
par bienveillance à l'égard du Parlement
que vous attendez également les
recommandations de notre commission
d'enquête pour checker tout ça et faire
un cocktail qui soit un peu plus
agréable au vu de l'enjeu
qui est le nôtre à savoir répondre aux
menaces de déstabilisation de notre
modèle républicain et
je crois qu'il serait utile
effectivement que dans
l'interministérialité ce cette inflexion
en tous les cas votre style plus en
phase avec les objectifs d'intérêt
supérieur de défense des idéaux
républicains soit soit mieux coordonnées
pour tirer enseignement au moins
des dysfonctionnements c'est le mot le
plus doux que je puisse utiliser
constaté sur la période précédente donc
je m'associe à la question de Jérôme
Bachar sur sur les aspects
d'organisation interne pour éviter
demain de se retrouver dans cette
situation et je tiens à réédir ici ce
sujet l'occasion de dire par ailleurs en
d'autres hémicycles le sujet qui nous a
amené à nous retrouver au sein de cette
commission d'enquête est un sujet
sérieux c'est la déstabilisation du pack
républicain avec l'assassinat d'un
professeur de la République et je pense
que la rigueur dans tous les cas que
vous nous avez présenté aujourd'hui et
le recaisonnement des pratiques et le
moins que l'on doit
en la mémoire de Samuel Paty et de
toutes celles et ceux qui avec vous avec
nous tous concours au respect des
valeurs républicaines et un autre modèle
d'intégration qui exclut par définition
toutes les logiques de cessation de
Sécession et de séparation républicaine
je vous remercie merci Jean-Michel on va
donner la parole rapporteur et puis
quelques mots à la fois de réponse de
conclusion de votre part madame
merci monsieur le Président je vais
inscrire une partie de mon propos dans
les interventions de Jérôme Bacher et de
notre collègue Jean-Michel
j'ai senti dans l'audition de ce matin
parfois une forme je pense d'irritation
lorsque nous avons
cherché à replacer le temps des
procédures et des validations
je j'entends ce que de nos collègues
gagnent de demander et qui à mon avis va
obtenir peut-être je me trompe mais une
réponse positive de votre part madame la
ministre sur ce que j'appelle une
méthode de travail une démarche
rigoureuse qui est une garantie de bonne
administration et de sécurité juridiques
des actes et des décisions politiques
puis administratives
ça c'est important deuxième élément
je reprends quelques uns de vos propos
parce que vous avez parlé à un moment du
dossier fond Marianne mais vous avez
aussi employé le mot dans vos propos il
y a quelques instants de l'affaire du
fond Marianne vous avez évoqué le fait
que peut-être les fautes seront
certainement sanctionnés dans les
prochaines semaines vous avez également
dit oui il y a eu des erreurs mais faut
pas tout jeter les derniers mots c'est
pas tout à fait ça c'est pas ceux que
vous avez utilisé mais je dis ça parce
que en moins d'une heure alors que vous
avez pris le relais du dossier on a de
la part de du gouvernement dans la
continuité républicaine des réponses qui
me paraissent plus en rapport avec les
éléments de notre questionnement
et ceux qui sont comment dirais
aujourd'hui mis sur la place publique je
le dis parce que ça n'a pas du tout été
le cas ce matin c'est juste pour poser
les éléments objectifs il faut
comprendre que pour des élus que nous
sommes en charge d'apprécier l'effet et
de contrôler l'action du gouvernement
dans ce domaine et ça n'est pas facile
on essaie donc de toujours garder cette
ligne mais je poserai une dernière
question finalement
est-ce que vous n'avez pas le sentiment
qu'il y a quand même un grand décalage
entre l'ambition initiale de créer
Jean-Michel Arnaud vient de le rappeler
dans un contexte atroce
d'un événement qui a glacé la France
c'est que je le redis qu'il y a donné un
sursaut d'unité républicaine avec une
annonce forte une ambition forte d'un
combat par tous les moyens
pour
aller plus loin que ce que l'État a
constaté c'est qu'il n'arrive pas à
combattre comme il le souhaiterait par
le seul système institutionnel les
discours séparatistes ou l'islamisme
radical
et en fait on a le sentiment c'est pour
ça que j'ai besoin de savoir si vous
partagez en tout ou partie que par
rapport à cette grande ambition tout ça
s'est amenuisé alors avec un manque de
rigueur ça ça paraît évident mais où on
n'a pas une grande visibilité même de
l'action et du bilan puisque on n'a pas
eu de communication qu'on n'est pas de
communication que le gouvernement essaie
de protéger les associations et c'est
les ceux qui les animent je comprends
mais on met quand même 2 millions
d'euros un tout petit peu plus et sur
quatre associations on attribue près de
1 million 400 000 euros donc on voit
qu'il y a quatre associations j'irai
majeures d'autres
qui ont moins mais qui travaillent
également est un certain nombre pour pas
dire je pense un grand nombre sont des
partenaires habituels de l'État et donc
la conclusion c'est le fond Marianne
une fois qu'on a qu'on aura
mis au clair ce qui a dysfonctionné de
plus ou moins grave c'est quand même son
objet et on en fait quoi aujourd'hui
quels enseignements on en tire sur
l'ambition et ce qu'on est au
rendez-vous un peu beaucoup très éloigné
c'est aussi important c'est important
évidemment qu'on contrôle l'utilisation
la bonne utilisation des sommes la bonne
organisation des de la sélection et des
choix mais je crois que ça a été dit par
plusieurs ce qui a été à l'origine du
fond et qui doit nous placer avec une
éthique de comportement et finalement
une droiture regarde la mémoire de la
victime je pense nous oblige encore plus
madame à la fois une réponse au 4
interventions et questionnements et en
même temps votre dernière conclusion
merci monsieur le Président alors
d'abord pour répondre au sénateur les
pratiques anciennes sont toujours
d'actualité
je sais pas si c'est de nature à vous
rassurer ou à vous inquiéter mais elle
est pratique anciennes sont toujours
d'actualité si ce n'est vous avez parlé
de validation de subventions je ne
valide pas les subventions je ne je n'ai
pas la liste des subventions c'est mon
cabinet qui le fait encore une fois dans
le cadre de l'impulsion politique qui
est la mienne de manière plus globale
sur sur la politique publique
ensuite la question qui est posée sur
globalement la quelle politique publique
est menée ça sera à la fois je vais je
vais répondre finalement en répondant à
cette question à l'ensemble des
questions qui ont été posées sur manière
plus globale d'abord pour dire que cette
politique allait menée par l'ensemble du
gouvernement il y a pas des des
ministres qui le font et d'autres qui le
font pas c'est bien une politique
publique qui est initié par le Président
de la République et qui est mené par
l'ensemble du gouvernement mais que nous
menons en tout cas que je mène à mon
niveau avec beaucoup d'humilité parce
que je vous le dis comme je le ressens
on a parfois le sentiment de vider
l'océan avec une petite cuillère quand
on s'attaque à ce sujet là
parce que finalement on le voit enfin
pour ceux qui sont qui sont ou qui ont
été des élus locaux
on a un travail extraordinaire qui est
fait dans les préfectures avec notamment
les clears qui visent à finalement petit
à petit découper déstructuré les réseaux
qui une fois qu'on les a coupés se
remettent en place aussi vite qu'on les
a cassés on a avec la loi crpr des
outils des outils nouveaux objectivement
assez extraordinaire notamment les
outils financiers pour là aussi enlever
les moyens à ceux qui qui s'en prennent
qui s'en prennent à la République et aux
enfants de la République en particulier
donc cette politique qui est menée elle
est menée sur le plan large et parler de
Pharos tout à l'heure qui s'attaque à la
haine en ligne qui est un sujet énorme
et sur les réseaux sociaux on travaille
pour construire notre notre politique
évidemment avec des universitaires le
sgcipdr travaille et reçoit des
universitaires j'ai moi-même eu
l'occasion d'en recevoir on travaille
avec l'iaei également sur ces sujets là
on a notamment un sujet je vais je vais
peut-être utiliser un mot que vous
connaissez pas mais qui est de
travailler sur du très bon King le
prebunking c'est de dire que quand
quelqu'un va chercher par exemple sur
les réseaux sociaux qu'est-ce que c'est
que la Baya quelques en fait que le
premier contenu qui est trouvé soit un
contenu qui soit plutôt produit par nous
pour alerter sur les risques de
séparatisme et de radicalisation c'est
un exemple par exemple mais qui est
porté par un certain nombre
d'universitaires et donc oui on
travaille sur ce sujet là dans plein de
direction là aussi encore une fois avec
beaucoup d'humilité certaines
fonctionnent certaines fonctionnent
moins bien en fonction des publics mais
je crois que c'est pas parce que on ne
voit pas de résultats immédiat vous
parliez tout à l'heure de la difficulté
de mesurer l'impact d'une vidéo qui a un
million de vues qui s'adresserait pas au
bon public c'est évidemment extrêmement
difficile à mesurer mais je pense que
c'est pas parce que c'est difficile à
mesurer qu'il faut l'abandonner et que
je pense que il faut continuer dans
toutes les directions que dont j'ai dont
j'ai donné quelques exemples aujourd'hui
continuer parce que au final on se rend
compte quand même que ça amène des
résultats ça amène des résultats
aujourd'hui je l'ai dit mais
malheureusement les prêches les plus
dangereux sont plus dans les mosquées il
l'était avant il l'était avant on a
quand même malgré tout évolué on a
aujourd'hui plus de prêche extrêmement
violents ou extrêmement dangereux dans
les mosquées dans les librairies dans
alors ça a été transposé ça disparaît
pas tout le travail qu'on est en train
de mener sur la question des
financements de ces réseaux
est absolument essentiel et petit à
petit on déstructure ce qu'on a en face
de nous mais c'est une politique
publique qui est difficile et je pense
qu'on a besoin sur ce sur ces sujets là
du soutien de tous et du travail
des services de renseignement des
préfectures et de l'ensemble des acteurs
voilà monsieur le président
merci madame la ministre et bonne fin de
journée à vous et à vos équipes